fan mail Friday this is a good question
from Deb
K oh there we go do your pets sleep with
you
Harold uh sometimes that's a boring
question three of them I mean three of
them three pets three dogs wow boy you
just let him just my Jack my Jack
Russell sleeps with me m my little dog
sleeps with my daughter my smallest my
second smallest sleeps with my son
Shannon biscuit bream does not sleep
with us where does he sleep she has her
own cushy luxurious like dog condo
situation oh wow that's pretty
interesting yeah wow she's very happy in
there she gets treats she goes in she
gets blueberries carrots it's night
night time judge you have like three
dogs right two or three two Pig three
three they all sleep with you uh no but
what they'll do is they'll come up to
the bedroom and they'll each come with a
toy when I say it's bedtime but they
don't come on the bed Jesse do they come
into your bed and play with your toue we
we just got it funny that you say that
we just got a and oh why is that a
bird wait wait wait a bird yeah the one
that talks why did you do that and so
rookie sleeps on the bed and now we have
this coatu and the coatu can get out of
the cage cuz we bought the wrong size so
it shimmies through the little bars and
then I find it fighting with rookie in
the middle of the night and then I have
to smack what kind of dog is rookie mini
poodle mini poodle and we're worried
that he's going to eat the coatu wow one
time he sneezed and one of the feathers
came out of his
mouth that's pretty good hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else